The Joe Rogan experience. Let's take it back to the day that this happened.
You're you're 22. You're logging you're you're in the woods.
Tell me what happened.
Well, uh, it was just, uh, you know,
when you're done working the hard physical labor,
everybody's kind of jacked up and there was a whole lot of chatter in the car.
We're just talking away, you know, starting to get dark,
we'd just loaded up our equipment. We're headed out.
And I looked up ahead and I saw this kind of glow coming through the trees.
First. I thought, no big deal, you know, we'd, it was deer hunting season,
uh, thought maybe there was some hunters camped up on the hill up there,
maybe light shine into a tent. It was still something really strange,
kind of caught my eye. And, uh, one by one,
the other guys in the crew started looking, but nobody said, oh my God,
what's that. Or anything like that,
it was just kind of an idle curiosity at first.
But when we burst into the clearing where we,
the source of this glow, uh,
it was just whoa. You know, I mean, it was just mind blowing instantly.
Uh, I,
I inexplicably <laugh> got out of the truck and ran toward this thing,
but, uh, I thought, I thought it was just gonna, uh, take off,
be gone in a flash. And so.
When you say in the clearing, so you you're, are you driving on a dirt.
Road? Yeah, it's a dirt road. Trees are real thick.
This was a part of the contract we hadn't cut in yet. So, uh, uh,
trees were a lot thicker there except for this clearing. And, uh,
uh, we weren't the only ones that saw it. We found out later,
uh, sheriff had on file, uh,
people who were in the area that saw it, you know, um, hunters and, uh,
fishermen over there at black canyon lake. And, uh,
the movement that they described was what the crew described when
it left. Um, and, uh,
of course I didn't see that, but, uh, what, what.
What did they.
Describe, uh, they described, uh, this glow rising up and streaking off,
I believe they said toward the Northeast. Uh, and, um,
I'm, there were some people that probably don't want to be public about it,
but there was one guy who was, uh, just deer hunting and, uh, he,
uh, worked in military intelligence and, uh, uh,
he stuck by what he and his wife saw. He, they were both, uh,
together and, uh, another guy that was at, uh, black canyon lake,
uh, um, I,
I won't mention any of those guys names unless they, uh, Joe do, but, uh,
um,
I found out later that there was more, uh,
official investigation that nobody talked about at the time.
Um,
immediately though this was all nonsense and these guys murdered him and, uh,
uh, even my oldest brother, he, he didn't believe him.
He thought they had killed me. Um, what we were doing with the, uh,
the brush that we cut was piling it up.
There were piles that were in the clearing so that the forest service could burn
these piles. Uh, you know,
when the conditions were right where it wouldn't spread, you know, um,
wet conditions otherwise, but, you know,
burning up this excess some material to reduce the fire danger in the woods.
And my, uh, oldest brother was tearing those piles apart.
He was certain that my body was under, under there,
and there were some pretty, um,
testy confrontations between him and my brother.
And I think even my other brother, Dwayne,
he initially took that approach,
but he quickly became sure that they were telling
the.
Truth. Now, you,
what do you remember when you were going through your mind? And you're trying,
I mean,
this is a story you've told so many times and the is a story that's been turned
into a film, which it's gotta be very surreal,
but when you look into your memories and you try to go back to that day.
Well, I don't try. That's something I try to block out, but, uh, uh,
it's UN it's unforgetable and there's, um.
What do you remember seeing when you ran into the clearing?
Well, um,
the whole clearing was lit up with this weird glow. Uh,
it's really hard to, uh,
for any artist or movie to try to duplicate the,
the strange, uh, uh, glow there was there made everything,
uh, look really, really pretty eerie, you know, and, uh,
uh.
Did it have a color.
To it? Uh, it was kind of a golden color,
but with a kind of a softness to it that was it wasn't like,
uh, beams of shooting out. It was just this, um,
haze of, of, of light.
And did it seem to come from a specific part of the.
Craft, or most of the surface seemed to be glowing.
There were darker areas that didn't, uh, give off light, but, uh, uh,
it was, uh, the parts you weren't glowing. It wasn't so hard,
uh, right. That, that you couldn't look at it. Uh, but it,
uh, had a metallic look to it.
So what did the craft itself look like?
It was, um, uh,
classic disc shaped, uh, craft, um,
the, uh, <laugh> years later, uh, um,
there was a report, uh, I can never remember names,
but this guy was in the, uh,
he worked at area 51 and they had something in there.
He worked with the tester model, uh,
corporation to create a model of,
of what he was describing and that that's actually the closest of, uh,
any of the other descriptions I've seen, but I don't think <affirmative>,
I don't think these things have just one type of craft.
I think there's many, many different shapes. What.
Makes you think that.
Well, personal experience? Uh,
I try not to emphasize these other incidents, but I've seen the, uh,
um, glowing sphere.
I've seen the giant black triangle, um,
um, other, other craft that were, um,
a ball of light that you couldn't penetrate the light with your eyes. But, uh,
now this.
Is after this.
Experience. Um,
I think the reason my brother Dwayne was, uh,
persuaded more quickly than my brother Don,
was that he saw a craft in the, those woods.
I was probably 10 miles for him there while deer hunting.
And, uh, it was kind of TAC shaped and that's, uh, something that's, uh,
been observed by, you know, in military reports.
Recently. Yeah. So you see this thing, this, uh,
this disc shaped craft. Yeah. And, and then what happens?
Yeah. Uh,
it started to move and started to get louder, louder. Yeah.
It was, uh, the guys in the truck heard it too. Uh,
there was a low, uh, um,
thunder is kind of a rumble that you actually sort
would've felt more than heard.
And then there were other high, high pitched frequencies.
I was talking to a group of, uh, um,
students from a technical college and they were really interested in what the
sound was like to try to, you know,
compare that with the theories that they had concerning what might be
their propulsion, but, uh, uh,
the increase in volume. It,
it suddenly got louder as it started to move. And, you know,
at the same time the guys in the truck were screaming, get away from there.
You know, let's go, let's go get back in the truck. Let's go. And, uh,
which would've been the smart thing to do, but as soon as it moved,
I startled me and I just ducked for cover. Uh,
it was log there. I, I got down behind this log and they were screaming.
Let's go, let's go, let's go. And, uh, I, uh,
didn't need to be told. I was just gonna, you know, stand up and run away.
But see, when I, when I jumped for cover, I, I,
I went down and forward to reach where the log would hide me. And,
uh, that brought me closer to it.
So when I stood up at that point,
that was the closest I was to the object, how close, uh, I,
I, it was still like eight or 10 feet away, you know, uh,
from the surface of it,
but that was when the energy discharge happened.
Um, I've worked on a number of theories about what might have happened at,
at the time some of the other guys on the truck were thinking, uh,
I mean, immediately Steve said it got him, like, you know, if you shot a deer,
you, you got it, you know? Right. And so, uh,
it might not have been,
as we assumed at first that it was some kind of Stu gun or something, but, uh,
maybe just closing that gap, uh,
allowed this energy to leap,
to ground through me and, uh, like static electricity or something. Yeah.
One thing that really, uh, weighs heavy in that direction is,
uh, that when, uh, I found years later that the, uh,
they, uh,
they have satellites or something that record the number of lightning strikes
and that area has the highest free frequency of lightning strikes of
any place in the continental United States,
except for the Everglades. Everglades has a bit more, but that's over water.
So that adds to another theory, what were they doing there? You know,
uh.
So that area that has a high level of lightning strikes,
do you think it makes sense that they're observing that? Or is that,
is that why they were there? Do you have any thoughts about.
That? Well, uh, until up until a few years ago, you know,
you walk down the rim road and if you see a tree that's been hit by lightning,
you can always see it. It's a drip,
a bark that just blasted out of there and it's all bare,
and it can actually still survive the lightning strike, but it turns the,
the, um, SAP to steam instantly. And it just explodes out the side of the,
uh, uh, tree blows the bark off. But, um,
I was at, uh, a conference where this lady was, I said, what's this?
And she says, that's fog. Right? I said, what? What's that? And she says,
that's when lightning strikes the earth,
you've got millions of vaults, millions of de agrees that form,
these crystals, that aren't formed geologically.
So I kind of leaned towards this theory that perhaps they were looking for Alite
for a very unique kind of crystal, uh,
that would be formed by, uh, that kind of blast of energy.
I'd never heard of folky for.
Hmm. Can you pull up an image in that Jamie,
I'd like to see what that looks like. I know, um,
trite night is something that happens when, uh, it's, uh,
they call it nuclear glass. It happens when there is, uh,
either a nuclear explosion or, uh, whether when, uh,
asteroid impacts hit the earth, that's it right there.
Well,
these crystals are supposed to have very special properties for people into
crystal stuff, but, uh.
What does that say there? Jamie? This is what happens. That's what strikes sand.
Wow. That's wild. It's beautiful. Isn't yeah, it really is. That's pretty wild.
So you might,
it might be that they were looking for that who maybe something that they use
for energy. What is that?
That's really when lightning struck Santa created that thing. That's wild.
That is wild. Look at that. It looks like a tree coming outta the sand.
Uh, I's guessing that's. That was wet sand. Yeah.
But, uh, yeah. Well, it's right next to the beach. It must be.
We mm-hmm <affirmative>. That is crazy. <laugh> that's really wild man.
Catch new episodes that Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify,
watch back catalog J E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video and
audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data cost. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify out to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.